yeah hello welcome to this video about
nine around nine of the butte tournament
um yeah again an exciting round really
am pretty amazing tournament with lots
of decisive fighting games we had one
draw today between unleash geary and
magnus carlsen where I think it was
pretty much equal all the way but it was
an interesting game nonetheless but well
draw at the end so Magnus um yeah keeps
his lead and this is due to one how
losing a game actually with black
against Victor bollig on the tail end of
the field but Beluga and played a really
interesting enterprising game against
one how and after very complicated
battle he won and this is actually am
also a hot candy data for for being game
of the day and the only issue being that
I just returned home yeah close to
midnight e in my time or one hour to
midnight so I simply don't have the time
to give this game a proper analysis and
make a video I think this is the kind of
game Larry could easily do a one hour
video and simply cannot make it today
and also um the other game which ended
decisively in buckroe Nakamura was
interesting as well so I'll take a look
at this and actually with this game I
feel I can ya give some pretty decent
information with the other game I mean I
could have shown it but I feel like I
wouldn't be able to do any decent
comentary at this time of day so on
let's do em back row roses la camera and
it starts with D for a crow played efore
last round and lost to geary so back to
deform and we got a sloth defense and
semi sloth actually yeah here white
cement rice of course I III and Bishop
g5
and back row opts for you three here
night bd7 and Quincy to which is one of
the the main lines here of the the semi
sloth Moran variation Bishop d6 and
Bishop d3 just developing pieces yeah
here black gown has some choice he can
also castle at this point which is yeah
maybe the most popular way to play this
so it's castles castles and here black
has various ideas but one main idea is
to just capture and play b5 and this is
interesting to look at because we got
something simulated the game but with a
very important twist so let's um go back
to the game now camera immediately took
on c4 which is a bit uncommon usually
you cancel first it took played b5 why
dropped the bash Bishop back to d3
here's a principled alternative is also
Bishop e2 the idea being that um let's
say continues we should be seven castles
castles rooty one that Y term can
position a rookie a directly opposite to
the Queen so that those freeing moves
are more difficult to have like to
achieve so the bishop on e2 also makes
some sense it is less good than
positioned here to play in the center
with you form so quite often there
should be three signals some other ideas
then this kind of setup words mostly
about trying to prevent on yeah make it
difficult for like to play those form
breaks in the game you played p53
we should be seven idea think I'm white
could have played them just castles he
didn't do it but he couldn't play just
castles here and I'm not quite sure I
think it's am most likely just a
transposition has some like castles now
we've got a 45 and we got a position
which has been played I'm quite a number
of times at some something like like
this here and the sun has been played
them couple of times already in the game
it said slightly different because he
plays efore immediately simply
threatening the fork on the two pieces
here so black needs to reply e5 takes
takes takes on e5 you should be five
yeah now still castles I think would
simply transpose to an online I'm not
sure that black has something better
than canceling himself so like castles
castles and then aged three would be the
main line but here back row tried
something else it late in F for which is
a very interesting move it has been
played before but this position is very
rare I just found them a couple of games
I think less than 10 games with this the
ideas of course very straightforward you
text the bishop and yeah like cannot
afford to make a passive mafia-like like
this one like Bishop here for instance
and some wide simply can approach it
with the 5 end it gets really a bit
tricky for black he played exactly the
way you should play played Bishop to d4
it's a much more logical of course also
because this is a really strong piece
preventing white from canceling short
and one
bishop in the middle of the board is
some yeah it's quite a good piece it has
a concrete idea though for white he
played me five now attacking the knight
which has to move and nakamura played 95
though I think my father the most
logical move could have considered this
one with the direct ideas but white
place the intended move 94 anyway and
the night is simply worse on g4 compared
to d5 as this idea is not possible
anymore this is a bit stranded this
piece on g4 I think it was some very
logical to go here in this position
white played 94 which is I think I'm the
best move he could have considered if
you want a somewhat simpler position he
could have considered to just take on d5
something like this and the idea being
to play rook t1 and try to do something
with this pin on the default like rugby
one Bishop see three things like this I
think this should be about equal maybe
but what white plate was more vicious
and not bad at all he played this 94 mph
and this of course has a very direct
threat so like needs to react now
instantly he played them Bishop to lie
to him to be formed and okay this is
some double attack the Queen needs to
move white them if white would want the
check here is it a media check the issue
is some you can just give the Queen here
and position like this is just just
losing for white but those two amazing
bishops and the d6 porn has no support
and will get lost it's next to pawn for
black and you should want it in activity
in addition so just then just
possible to play he needed to go here
which is some what he did and now he
care awam well the snide was also
hanging just great leadership cm and
castles and this is really a a pretty
interesting position where I'm why does
God's I mean you can put the next news
on the board it's got this great night
on v6 which heavily restricts our
black's pieces so what black is playing
now pretty much amounts to 22 being the
only if we move that it's playable
Bishop c5 the bishop of course also was
hanging and what he wants to do simply
as to to take this piece you cannot
tolerate a knight down Bishop c5 the
only move now wide when we should be
three which is also i think the best
move need to get here your staff
developed but here black captured only
six you need to get rid of the night of
course wide them after taking with the
porn obtains the dangerous passed pawn
on the default but you simply cannot
play against such night on v60 you
needed to take and black has got some
compensation for this this some new
sincere with the deep on he can give
this check which he did and now we see
that whites king it's in a bit of a bit
of a bother here what what should white
clay he played g3 which is logical but
it very much weakens the light squares
and of course black has owned a nice
bishop him that might use the long
diagonal he could have considered
playing a king move but this is also
very ugly the move like this year looks
simply simply ugly for white it's not
completely lost or something but looks
difficult black would most likely just
jettison the poor Nia I possibly right
what would take but taking here for
example
it's very dangerous after this move with
the threat should take three to winning
the Queen and if the Queen move
somewhere them like a black just obtains
a very strong attack moving the King
doesn't really help the King I mean g3
is a move let's just return the a23
woods really weak and squares and you
don't want to do that but well the
weekend squares I'm mostly a problem for
the King position and the King position
I have one is also bad so g3 is
perfectly okay Queen to h5 Queen h3 also
was a possible we need Troy and this
position um young white needs to think
about what what legs next move might be
what is intention is and it's pretty
obvious that black next move will be c5
no matter what wide place next move will
be c5 you absolutely need to get this
piece into play if why it's just them
yeah just them to show it let's say an
alternative um rooks you want just to
show if black now plays some some slow
move um which doesn't really ya all to
the position let's say something like
this year then white can simply put them
put a piece on c5 and block all this
maybe black has got some some other
technical idea i can maybe can play
something like bishop see aid in this
concrete position actually allowing them
to stay i'm not sure what i want to say
is this bishop needs to play and c5 is
the move that black gum really a must
must play at some point cuz just not
caring about a pawn so black on rook see
one will play c5 it's just it just
mandatory you need to get this piece
into play and then it might continue
Roxy five note that this rope was
hanging with Roxy five also attacks the
Queen
so maybe queen age 3 next move and group
g1 and it's really a messy position
there are also alternatives instead of
taking on c5 white coat down also I just
I just mess up the move water I think
Roxy one is work to what he played oh
I'm sorry this is the game continuation
and what I was wanting to show is what
could also um casal here what could also
cancel him lens c5 activating the bishop
as mentioned and then something like
this f5 c4 Queen d4 and very unclear
position I think leg should be ok
because while this King position is a
cause for concern all the time with this
really strong b7 bishop but this is
really a strong past porn so a very
unclear complicated position it could
could end yeah all three results are are
possible in this kind of game the kind
of example where um opposite squared the
opposite couple bishops here in no way
related raw because queens are on the
board and white skin was weakened very
complicated so castles want a serious
alternative he played Roxy one and I
just confused them those two moves them
before and rook see one was answered by
dimension c5 black doesn't want to see a
piece on c5 blocking the bishop so c5
frees up this piece and Crosswhite
captured here attacking the Queen and
Queen moved away but now I'm while the
rookies hanging and it needs to move so
after work g1 blankets able to UM to
capture on h2 and restore material
equality
wyd also could have considered Regev one
it's not another stupid move look I have
one with the possible continuation Queen
takes and rook f2 this is a quite
interesting idea leading to on this kind
of position where song Lee whites whites
rooks get very active something like
like this and it's it's really a total
mess this position really hard to tell
what's what's going on just for example
of blood place f6 white don't even
consider taking him and then putting
bishop on deform and this is a yeah well
totally crazy don't know what's going on
White's d porn is strong now whites
bishop has got a nice position it's
totally unclear I think what not much
time on the clock it's pretty much like
a game of roulette out this sir how this
might end so I'm some interesting
alternatives but back row played the
yeah the simple looking rook g1 not bad
not bad at all so Carol grab the graph
the pawn on h2 and I whoopsie to to get
rid of this this annoying Queen it
dropped back to h3 and now Roxy seven so
first driving the Queen to a somewhat
less attractive post and now the repeat
texts the bishop yeah this Bishop
actually doesn't have so many squares
bishop f3 is pretty much the only move
and we cannot protect it them because
the combination of this stuff and d7 is
just it's just just deadly now why just
threatens to take and then promote the
pond very ugly am hopeful black if you
move the bishop now which she needs you
then you can we can simply grab here and
everything saying so on
not not very nice he needs to move the
bishop and hehe one Bishop f3 which is
pretty much the only move in this
position I'm white plate Kingda to
getting the King out of the e-file also
he had an alternative which I I would
have preferred a thing and it looks
better to me this is king of tune but of
course this is all super complicated and
we see looking at the time that back row
was down to 12 minutes well Nakamura was
pretty much blitzing out his moves was
still on one hour something so pretty
amazing very quickly later all this so
what came up to what does it do it
simply threatened this bishop and the
bishop needs to move again there's not
much else then the Sun would
weird-looking Bishop h1 the problem
being if black can would go here to G
form then this Queen d Fife is pretty
annoying rook h1 threads to win the
Queen it is trapped and would what
should should black play now to attend
to this I think he needs to play we
should be six attacking attacking this
Queen and yeah at this point wider could
simply take here or could consider the
funny move rookie ch1 with some Muslim
counter-attack this kind of endgame for
example is so excellent for white
because now the deep on really pays off
and it's not a problem anymore that you
have a somewhat Airy King here because
to the Queen south why should be a clear
year preferred in this position so this
is interesting this rook h1 what happens
if black moves the Queen let's say here
then white can go Queen h5 threatening
made and it's a queen trade after all I
think this King have to move with really
are worth considering
and some not quite sure how black gum
should defend this if white gets rid of
the Queen's he has very serious winning
chances but you played King Detroit it's
not bad I mean King f2 looks a little
bit more let's say yeah little more
solid to me trying to get rid of the
Queen's but while the smooth is not bad
it's not bad King be too so black now
played Queen to e6 the Queen wasn't
doing so much anymore and h3n2 know this
squared actually attacks upon and my
tongue help to get the bishop to you
form so quite a logical move and white
now with Bishop c5 which is also pretty
obvious the idea you want to push the
seven and take the look on so with the
bishop and you also just make sure that
the spawn doesn't drop at any point it's
always nice to be protected now by the
bishop and at the same time of course
why just the text this this f three
piece he dropped this to g4 let's look
quickly what happened down what happened
at this move it's possible but if white
just responds here with a normal reply
you've get this idea coming pinning the
some suspicions and black needs to play
some pretty unnatural move now to even
make sure that you don't lose it take
note you cannot cannot go f5 at some
point because I can actually move it at
some huge blunder better just to show it
yeah white could turn just play Queen g7
check made now so pretty transport on
the bottle it's a checkmate you cannot
play a five to make sure your bishop is
only secure square made this more
important at all so on you need to
attend to this P should be forced not
good so I need to need to
go here and and here what can none try
to improve his position further with B 3
which he actually did in the game a two
were saying so a normal simple move and
yeah well somehow it seems that the tech
that black hat so it's going nowhere and
this pawn is getting stronger and
stronger you can plate now Bishop f5
also quickly trying to put more pressure
on white goose down to nine minutes yeah
and here in this position what can you
say it was just starting to get get
really really interesting here
microplate rupee one until you should
just take let's say five seconds and
think about what lag should play now
I'll give you five seconds and you can
stop the video of course ya hear me
corona camera just played Queenie one
and wide resigned so after this is just
a rug up yeah well it's a nice to see
that even a super grandmaster slide back
row can just blunder rook on a bad day
yeah he really did that he just lived
London to holbrook in this position with
rookie one and he was down to nine
minutes so it wasn't like a really
serious time travel yeah and the most
annoying thing about this I think white
had a pretty good position here if white
plays some place a normal movie and the
Queen was attacked you so let's say I'm
white place Queen to e2 just just to
show to put a move on the ball if black
now gives this check on d5 what can
actually step up with a king doesn't
mind
position so much and now attends stuff
like rook d 1 and d 7 and like i said we
huge trouble here this check i think is
actually mistake when you five check one
huge problem being a frog fe8 here then
why just place this very simple move but
it's terribly strong the point being if
now Queen to you form the Queen was in a
way attacked you cannot exchange anymore
because an end game like this just lose
this d 7 wins material next move Black
has no way to prevent this so here the
Queen really needs to move and let's say
it goes to you for also can actually
play it then yeah then White has more
than one good move but this is this is
really strong attacking the bishop going
here just drops it so you pretty much
need to go here and after have seven
yeah well where should the bishop go
there's simply no square and let's say
here then white can just trying to get
rid of the Queens and then after this is
just winning because the deep on will
promote thankee em here white is winning
so this Queen d5 check actually just
helps why it's because you got rooked
you one with the 10 book when you want
with the temple so this checks are just
bad so let's say Queen h6 trying to
avoid the the Queen trade I think here
um watch maybe play rook e1 the problem
what you would like to do the first kind
of move that to you you get in your mind
is queenie seven but this is actually a
very bad blunder as the Queen doesn't
have a square of course it has square
okay it can go here but that sir it's
terrible what white skin will get we get
mated here in the end you nothing so it
cannot cannot do that but you can play
rook e1 let's mention this just to pass
this move as rookie aid now it's of
course simply answered with the capture
and you've got made into and the air
what what what should black play yards
really have a problem you don't have
many moves and white is intending to
play d 7 so let's say you play nothing
move like a six then d7 just win the
game it's just it's just over nothing
but I can do something like this gets
punished immediately was with Queenie 8
and you're still check me get made it in
the end so black cannot afford to make a
nothing move it pretty much needs to put
a rock on the aid if you place rook a 2d
eight then yeah why can can can push
this I need no no it's protected sorry
I'm sorry but what can can play
something like this year with the idea
after we should move to play maybe Queen
g5 and this d7 move run gets more and
more dangerous and this also possible
but now white can actually play this if
you want I can consider ok send simply
because again this fails to Queenie 8
Queenie Ainsworth with me to boom
checkmate so I think white had a really
good position when he made this terrible
blunder it's not completely clear
captain especially considering that the
time situation but i think it was wide
was the one with the advantage in this
position and
going rupee one here was just just
really a terrible blunder yeah back row
had two very up and down tournament he
want a very nice game against for rizzle
which at the beginning what lost
terribly a couple of games after this so
we can wear one again and but he's not
done able to win the tournament anymore
before the last round and this really
promises a fun last round we've got
magnus carlsen leading with 17 points
remember this three point system Magnus
has got 17 points leads alone and then
we've got Geary and Wang Hao following
with 16 points there just one point
behind the final round game is Carlton
with white against back row so win
against back row was not really in top
shape would net cards in the the
tournament win and ok most like him he
may be many were manages so he might win
this tournament just by winning himself
but it's just a one-point lead and if he
just plays a draw against back row even
loses then Geary and Wang Hao with a win
could um well actually am still win the
tournament and they play each other in
the last round so we've got Giri against
one how long how Giri how it's got the
white pieces so I think they most likely
will put up you try trying to still win
the tournament which which would be a
huge success of course for both of them
and but Magnus has the opportunity with
the win Ernest own to to get a
straightforward tournament win of course
this son we have them the third game is
son nakamura against below gone where
Carol certainly will try to to win again
to ya get closer to the leaders but he
cannot win the tournament anymore the
loss against one how really ended all
ambition son in this respect last one
yeah right thanks for watching hope you
enjoyed it it wasn't
sund end of this game but it was still
pretty interesting I guess yeah thanks
for watching and I'll do a video on the
last round as well cheers and bye